d'une guerre à l'autre l'Ukraine à
présent pour la première fois la Russie
admet que des soldats ukrainiens ont
réussi à franchir le fleuve du nièpre
ils ont atteint la rive gauche zone
occupée par Moscou les Russes affirment
cependant avoir immobilisé leurs soldats
en leur faisant subir un enfer ce sont
leurs mot Emmanuel Chaz on vous retrouve
dans la région de nicolaiv bonjour à
vous de quelles informations
disposez-vous sur cette avancée
ukrainienne bonjour Julien et bien
effectivement les forces ukrainiennes
euh se serait implanté sur la rive
opposée du Dnipro opposée à la ville de
Herson hson qui est sous les
bombardement quasi constant en tout cas
quotidien puisque les Russes sont
toujours occupent toujours la rive
opposée à la ville alors ces incursions
ukrainiennes de l'autre côté de la rive
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'elles
arrivent mais là c'est la première fois
que les Russes le confirment et c'est la
première fois qu'il partent du qu'il
parle d'une implantation c'est aussi ce
que dit keV sans bien s sûr que nous les
journalistes nous puissions le vérifier
puisque nous n'avons pas accès à cette
rive opposée et cette rive tre
éminemment dangereuse puisque les Russes
l'utilisent pour bombarder comme je le
disais plusutôt cette ville de hson donc
c'est une zone extrêmement dangereuse
Helson qui est sous les bombardements un
peu plus tôt aujourd'hui le centre de la
ville a encore été touché encore été
frappé pour l'ensemble de la région
juste pour vous donner une idée on parle
de plus de de de 20000 bâtiments qui ont
été endommagés hein depuis l'invasion à
grande échelle de l'Ukraine par la
Russie donc ici à mikolayev dans la
région juste voisine un peu plus tôt on
entendait les tirs d'artillerie on
entendait les bombardements dans cette
région voisine donc toute donc toute la
région évidemment est en état d'alerte
quasi constant merci beaucoup pour ces
précisions Emmanuel Chaz pour France 24